what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I want to be a little bit
dangerous here and I want to ask the
question can Iron Man make Infinity
stones well really anybody in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe can they make
Infinity stones the reason why I say
Ironman is I guess spoilers for a movie
that's been out for me almost someone uh
everybody who's capable except for Iron
Man dies like anybody capable of doing
anything because there's no Professor X
there is no Doctor Doom there's no Reed
Richards and Peter Parker's gone like
the scientific powerhouse of the MCU
is Iron Man and really always has been
in terms of like science and technology
it's always been that way if Reed
Richards were there in the MCU I would
say I'll definitely read probably could
uh but you know while we have is really
Iron Man I guess it's kind of
interesting when you look at it in the
greater scope of the characters who are
seen in the MCU versus the characters
who are available wood throughout Marvel
as a whole and it's like man all they
really have is Iron Man because I mean
there's a ton of people out there
they're like a ton of super geniuses you
have pretty much anybody from Aim you
have advanced idea mechanics you have
pretty much you know you got Reed
Richards you have Adam Brashear you have
black war black panther but he's gone
too but like I mean you have like
Panther I guess maybe Sheree you know
it's sure you might be able to pull it
off because science is so advanced but
okay here's here's the thing here's the
thing
all right let's kind of answer this
question can Infinity stones be created
and the answer of that question is
actually yes Infinity stones can be
created and Marvel Comics you can make
an infinity stone to copy the existing
Infinity stones now no one ever does
that
I mean Marvel Comics has never given us
a situation like that and the reason why
is I probably say for a few different
reasons one because if you do that in
the comics well then you open the
floodgates if Reed Richards can make
Infinity stones then why can't dr. doom
and why can Adam Brashear and why can't
black panther and why can't any of these
people out there who were who are super
smart how come they can do it you know
and so so really it's it's easier to
simply not even open that can of worms
in the first place to basically say the
Infinity stones are just kind of like
these objects that are a physical aspect
of the universe made you know made made
tangible it's easier to say that than
anything else not only that if somebody
could duplicate and create an infinity
stone it would take away from the
significance of the Infinity stones
themselves of the Infinity Gauntlet
because whenever someone gets a hold of
the
Marvel Comics it doesn't matter who it
is if it's Iron Man if it's Parker
Robbins if it's Captain America it
doesn't matter who the person is if
somebody gets a hold of it then it's
like oh my god like like if we're not
careful were screwed like that was the
whole thing behind Infinity Gauntlet
right like the Infinity Gauntlet story
happens Thanos gets the gauntlet goes
nuts and then nebula gets it from him
and the people are just like oh my god
she's gonna go crazy like like we have
no idea what she's gonna do she's not
pursuing power she's just a chick with a
broken mind who got ahold of absolute
power and so it gets kind of crazy you
know kind of hairy in that situation so
but but the funny thing about this is
that the Infinity stones do not
manipulate anything that doesn't already
exist right like they just manipulate
the fundamental forces of the universe
they like at least that's what the
reality stone does but like the time
stone does the same thing it just
manipulates two points in time in the
history of the universe the mind stone
manipulates thoughts and that's kind of
the funny thing in Marvel Comics
everything is energy right like like
everything is energy and it didn't used
to be that way it used to be that in
Marvel you had two fields you basically
had like two sides of this coin you had
the magical side and the non magical
side the magical side was really
explained in like Gary freed by a by
Gary Friedrich rather in 1971 with tales
to astonish number eight and the idea
was okay so Doctor Strange can do what
he does because he's using the energy of
other beings out there and that energy
allows them to manipulate all different
kinds of things you know and so it's
like you want to buy a car right like
you know it's a fifty thousand dollar
car out there that you want to buy but
you don't have fifty thousand dollars so
you go to a bank and borrow it and then
you get that $50,000 car that's what
Doctor Strange does in and of himself
Stephen strange is the weakest person
ever and even with all the spells he has
like anybody who knew that Stephen
strange as doctors me as Doctor Strange
himself they could just snipe him from a
rooftop and he's dead if he can't cast a
spell in time that's the end of him
that's this really all it is unless of
course he hasn't been champion around
himself to make himself bulletproof at
all times which is entirely possible but
like if the Punisher wanted to kill him
he could just take him out that fast and
that's it it's the spells he uses from
other mystical beings out there that
allow him to do the kind of things he
does now the other side of the equation
is non magical beings basically mutants
and individuals who have various super
powers when it comes to like non magical
beings Marvel never had rules for that
they were just there like you know doc
like not
strange um Professor Xavier of the x-men
could read minds because that's just
what he does and like Jean Grey could
read minds because that's just what she
does there were times when like
explanations for character's abilities
basically came into existence as the
years went on for example Cyclops who
didn't really have an explanation in
terms of how his powers worked he just
removed his ruby course glasses or
opened up his optic beams and like you
know uh concussive force just came
flying out of his eyes and that was it
it wasn't until years later that you
learned that the eyes of Cyclops are
actually portals to a dimension of pure
energy and when he opens his eyes the
portal opens and bam all that energy
comes out and that's it you know we
never really got like explanations in
the early days of Marvel now again
because of the fact that magic was so
weird
even on the magical side things got a
little it got a little chaotic for
example you had dr. Stephen strange who
is a sorcerer supreme
and then you had Agatha Harkness and it
was like what I get for hardness is an
actual witch like she's not a sorcerer
like she's not a sorceress she's a witch
but there was no real difference between
what Agatha Harkness did and what Doctor
Strange did they basically did the same
thing they just did it by two different
means and because of the fact that
Marvel was kind of splitting hairs to
basically offer you know an explanation
of how these two characters differed in
relation to non magical beings who could
kind of do the same thing then suddenly
it became really confusing and it became
really wild this was also another
situation that really kind of began to
give rise when you sort of seen
characters like the molecule man Owen
Reese who could just work the universe
you know who could control the very
fundamental forces of reality itself to
Beyonder you know like like Mad Jim
Jasper's like all these crazy
reality-warping beings it was nuts the
kind of power they possess and so Marvel
sat down one day and almost said okay we
need to kind of have an explanation that
ties all this together we can't so let
me just have like magic lets you do
things and these things let you do
things and so when Fantastic Four number
500 what Mark Waid did is he basically
sort of brought all these things
together and he said okay so here's how
these things work and what was basically
established here is that everything in
the universe is composed of energy and
that's it when you think something the
thoughts that you have actually resonate
to the to the astral plane the astral
plane have been around for years years
and years and years and years it's been
around for a long time ever since this
reached strange tales comics in like in
like 1963 they've been it had been
around forever but nobody ever bothered
to kind of make the connection to
basically save it like there's no real
between what dr. strange does and what
like Professor Xavier does they just do
it by two different means instead it was
the magical side the non magical side
and that was it but by saying that
everything is energy that in turn it
makes things a whole lot simpler because
what you have is exactly what you've
always had just dr. strange manipulating
the universe and the Scarlet Witch
controlling the universe is just who has
a greater control over the universe is
really all that is and that really kind
of came to a head with Infinity Gauntlet
right like back in 91 92 the Infinity
Gauntlet story really shifted things up
because it really kind of took like the
powers of dr. strange and said well you
have no power here
like sure there's everything that you
can do but you're helpless in the face
of the Infinity Gauntlet and that's when
people started asking questions well if
dr. strange uses magic and it's a wholly
separate set of power than what the
Infinity Gauntlet does then how can the
Infinity Gauntlet basically hold sway
over dr. strange and prevent him from
being able to topple it couldn't just
cast a spell to in order to make sure
the Infinity Gauntlet doesn't work or
something like that that's when those
themes started to blend together so
here's the way things work in Marvel
Comics right now in terms of this moment
that we're recording this video whatever
day it is in May May 22nd 2018 I don't
know what they were recording this video
whatever day it is all right what you
basically have is you have three tiers
of energy now again this all comes out
of a Fantastic Four number 500 right the
first you have the first thing you have
is personal energy is the energy of your
own body now different people use this
in different ways but it really is just
like basic energy manipulation for
example like Iron Fist uses his own
physical energy to create the actual
Iron Fist itself like that's what Danny
Rand does but then you have Bruce Banner
The Incredible Hulk who draws on his own
energy which is literally just like a
like drawn off his own his own actual
anger his emotional state and that
pushes his strength even further it's a
little ad hoc but it works for the
purpose that it serves you have
individuals who can basically make
themselves invisible you have people
like like like Wolverine who uses his
own energy in order to basically heal
himself now when it comes down to
personal energies there's only ever
really two types there's what's called
passive and there's what's called active
passive energy basically means that it
happens whether you wanted to or not
like it's just the way it works
Wolverines healing factor as a passive
is a passive energy as a passive power
like his body will heal itself whether
he wants it to or not he can't control
his healing factor it can be taken away
but he can't really control it but then
you have someone like bishop who has an
active power meaning that when Bishop is
blasted with any any kind
physical energy were hit with a physical
you know hit physically it transfers
energy from you know whatever he's been
blasted with or whatever the physical
force is into the body of Bishop which
he absorbs and then he can channel it
back out into like a physical you know
instead of like a actual energy beam or
something like that but it's literally
just energy transference is really all
that is but it's still personal but
again that's just an example I mean
another really good example and how it
ties into the Infinity stones when we
say personal energy like telepathy like
one of the things that people ask about
in Marvel Comics is how does telepathy
work this Charles Xavier really just
read the minds of individuals does he
jump into their heads to a degree he can
I mean he can he can do that but what it
is is basically energy manipulation on a
personal level in Marvel Comics when you
think a thought your thought actually
radiates out into the astral plane
that's how people like the shadow king
can hold sway over individuals literally
every single thought that you have of
every single day in the Marvel Comics
universe radiates out into the astral
plane at the same time like every time
you go to sleep and you dream your
thoughts your subconscious you know
dream thoughts whatever it is you know
what happens in the subconscious mind
radiates out into the dream dimension
which is where the Doctor Strange
villain nightmare resides now the dream
dimension was basically created when
like the first sentient being had its
dream and then it's just kind of been
growing ever since
as a result of like all the dreams that
all the sentient beings have ever had
it gets pretty metaphysical when you
start talking about that kind of stuff
but that's the way it works like though
those are actual things what someone
like Charles Xavier does is he really
like intercepts is what it is like
Charles Xavier will read your mind and
he'll basically intercept your thoughts
on the way to the astral plane now if
there like a way in is a way out
basically and so if there's a way into
the astral plane or a way out of here
like if your thoughts make their way out
of your mind somebody can make their way
into your mind and that's what Xavier
does it's almost like swimming against
the tide of thoughts into your head and
then seeing what it is a you hath you
can put thoughts in there take thoughts
out the whole nine yards but all it's
doing is just manipulating your mind in
terms of how it works with regards to
the astral plane but then from there you
move on to what's called dimensional
energy now dimensional energy it gets
kind of iffy because someone like Doctor
Strange doesn't just draw on dimensional
energy but like Cyclops for example is
dimensional energy again like he opens
his eyes energy from from you know
another dimension flows through his eyes
and comes out in the form of a
concussive force but like another
example is juggernaut like juggernaut
uses what's called the Crimson gem of
cyttorak Siddha rock being one of the
elder
that existed on earth and took off when
the Demiurge started killing all the
gods all the Elder Gods and then took
off into the Sun but basically like
sidorak resides in the crimson dimension
now inside of his own dimension crimson
like Alexa Dirac is insanely powerful I
would say nine unstoppable inside of his
own dimension now once he leaves he's
like Mephisto like Marvel's devil right
like the longer Mephisto stays away from
his own dimension of Hell the weaker he
gets with sin Iraq it's time to the same
way but not really mama doesn't really
show SID Iraq leaving his own dimension
that much in fact I don't think it's
ever really happened since the octets
and since like the the day was the day
nine event the the the day the eight day
event eighth day yeah the eighth day
event which was like eighth day
juggernaut where he was just like crazy
Opie but nonetheless like like those are
the kind of things that go on in in
terms of that like you know the like
sitter rock put his put a portion of his
power into the Crimson Jim and that's
why when Kay marco stumbled upon it he
basically read the inscription you know
you who read these words shall bestow be
bestowed with her crimson power city
rock ya areata you will go forth for
evermore a human juggernaut and that's
that's kind of how that whole thing
works he picks up the Jim and he's
imbued with the energy of Sid Iraq
someone like dr. strange again it gets
kind of hairy because almost all of dr.
Strange's powers come from extra
dimensional beings they come from from
beings that exists in different
dimensions but outside of the main
Marvel Universe so in the main Marvel
Universe think of it like your house
right like in the in the main Marvel
Universe you have like your living room
and like your master bedroom and like
your kitchen you have your common areas
but your common areas would be like the
universe and then a closet like if you
open the the you know like the closet
were like the entry closet where you
hang your coat that would be Asgard and
if you open the the closet leads into
the laundry room that would be like you
know the Dark Dimension where you know
Dormammu who lives there something like
that they all exist inside of a singular
universe but you can access them through
certain doorways portals or
what-have-you but the fact remains here
that when it comes to like universe or a
dimensional energy it's literally just
drawing on the energy of another being
that exists out there but again with
someone like Doctor Strange pretty much
all the power he derives comes from
another dimension it comes from like the
vishanti or it comes from watoomb or it
even comes from Siddha rock himself in
the form of the crimson bands which you
saw and doctors in the infinity were
like when he locks Thanos and those
those bands those are the crimson bands
of cyttorak
those are the kind of things you see
that's why they didn't call them the
crimson crimson bands of cyttorak
because CID Iraq is tied into the x-men
mythos so they can't really use sin Iraq
because of the Fox you know Fox and
Disney rights but basically that's
that's how that whole thing plays out
but he draws a lot of his energy from
other dimensions and so what that does
is basically just allow him to use those
energies for any one particular purpose
from there you have like universal
energy and it's basically the energy of
the universe is really all it is now
when we say the energy of the universe
it's not like the energy of the universe
at this point in time it's the energy of
the universe all energy that has existed
currently exists and does exist in the
future and that's why individuals like
Trevor Fitzroy can jump back and forth
through time is because what he's doing
is he's basically manipulating universal
energy for the purpose of like jumping
around now that's the temporal aspect
the time aspect of you know Universal
energy but he's basically jumping from
one point in time in the universe to
another point in time in the universe
but he can't leave right like he can't
jump from like the main Marvel Universe
to the real world by opening a portal it
doesn't work that way he can only
manipulate Universal energy back and
forth by manipulating time but because
of the fact that that's nothing more
than just tapping into existing energy
it's entirely possible for for someone
like Iron Man to create Infinity stones
because what he would be doing is
basically harnessing the power of time
that's really it like like if he can
make a time machine he can make a time
stone when it comes to doing something
like like manipulating the energy of the
mind it's just intercepting or figuring
out how the mind works we already know
they did that when it came to when it
came to the vision they literally took
all that like they basically said the
mind stones really nothing more than
just a really really advanced computer
system inside of a little stone that's
it
they establish that an age of Ultron
when it comes to something like the
reality stone that's when things get a
little hairier but I would imagine it's
like tapping into the magic like
literally Steven stranger I'm sorry uh
you know turning Starks sitting down
with Wong and just saying like teach me
everything that you told you taught dr.
strange about like how the universe
works and like universal energy and then
just creating a device that can tap into
that energy that's really all it is it's
just a matter of tapping into a type of
energy and nothing more so I think it's
entirely possible for for Ironman to
create his own Infinity stones now the
question is will he well I doubt it I
think that'd be too far fetched like I
have a hard time believing that like
Marvel wouldn't
a movie where doctorate where like
Ironman would create infinity stars it'd
be cool but like that's never happened
like nothing like that's ever happened
before in Marvel Comics I think that
would really be like uncharted waters ah
I'd be curious to see how that works I
mean I would legitimately be curious if
let's say that happens let's say that
like Avengers 4 picks up an Iron Man
makes his own Infinity Gauntlet like
that would actually be pretty beast like
an iron like an Infinity Gauntlet or an
infinity stone powered Iron Man suit
could you imagine that
like that would be I mean he would be
he'd be God man is what he would be iron
God like it would it would be nuts
like like maybe one of the craziest
displays of like technological
advancement ever in the history of like
Marvel Comics or the movies I'm kind of
curious do you guys think Iron Man could
create his own Infinity stones in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe again I think
it's pretty far-fetched you know I can't
really envision a circumstance in which
this will happen but that's the point of
these Theory videos it's just like throw
whatever kooky idea we have and just
like throw it out there and just see how
people respond to it so let me know what
you guys think but without being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Robin core if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]